that's why I don't like kale watching
Disney moveme movies anymore
it's because she's starting to say
Prince Charming is gonna save me
oh my gosh are you kidding me and it
still it I do understand why parents
don't allow their kids to watch certain
shows right I don't think they should
ban them from watching shows VeggieTales
is a good way to go or know VeggieTales
is still popping right now yeah
cucumbers cucumbers and the tomatoes you
know and but they're all about
positivity and like with disney music
music movies they really embed in there
in the kid's brain cuz I have to watch
like five to watch it like numerous of
times right because of khaya and now I'm
adult so I'm really watching this as
that's why you got to show this without
real humans like Lion King you know
saying yeah it it really is about Prince
Charming and it's about false false
hopes and false dreams about false
fantasies well that's what I think
everybody liked about the let it go
what's that one called frozen cuz it was
about two strong female characters right
and there wasn't a prince charming there
to save everybody there was a male
figure there trying to save somebody but
he wasn't one that saved the day it was
a sister you know so I don't I don't
know like for me I want to mind them
watching Disney but I do understand it's
hard to get a kid to understand that
there isn't this this magical world I
think there's a lot of positivity and
love in this world but you can't expect
this miss male figure to come and save
you every time it's maybe a several
frozen but you go know that great music
though yo I'm gonna be honest right now
when you start watching Street red I
don't buy that damn you have a good
voice if only they'd look closer would
they see a po-boy no siree relax
yeah oh sure they find out there's so
much more to me yeah [ __ ] that movie you
know what
Williams right now I love Romulus but
this is what I heard okay and I was like
whoa like you know like brown people go
no you know but no no someone made a
point where this goes to the prince
charming jasmine falls in love with the
[ __ ] crook he's a [ __ ] crook he's
not a crook he's a riff raff street rat
I don't buy that if only they'd look
closer she's talking about you right now
he's talking about you if only she'd
look closer no it would they see a
po-boy no she won't
there's no there's nothing because I
he's just a big ol [ __ ] no but this
person made a lot of sense saying you
know like it's showing kids like that
you can steal and you still can be you
know they're not they're not showing you
that you could steal and be Prince
Charming you have to look at the whole
situation right but you think of it as a
child it's like what your way I don't
think that's what kids are thinking
though I don't think when I was a kid I
what look Aladdin came out when we were
kids I never thought from once watching
that film that stealing was okay but I
thought bad boys are pretty hot well
that's cool you all [ __ ] up my daddy's
girls love bad boys right yeah but you
know I don't think I think you're
looking too into it because because
yourself cuz you're saying cuz cuz
you're actually doing the exact opposite
of what you're saying you're saying
right now that kids don't know any
better and that's what they're gonna
take away from it and I'm telling you me
as a kid right yeah okay all I thought
was cool magic carpet a lot of great
magic something happens in the end that
makes me happy there's no way that a
young child is thinking oh stealing is
really cool and if I steal this is best
because that's not even anywhere near
the notes that are expressed in that
film that's such a small part of the
film that just gets glazed over
okay here's the thing as a parent as a
mother who has a child I know you're
coming through experience right yeah but
I'm watching these movies with her right
and I'm really seeing that I don't like
these movies they they actually say bad
words like I don't want my child to hear
the word stupid cut repeatedly right
because she wants to watch these movies
they actually the if you start watching
the stuff with your kids you start
noticing the stories the actual
characters the actual intentions someone
I don't know if I can't give you another
perspective though you yes you may so
you are also looking this as the eyes of
somebody as an adult who has been
through a lot of things right so your
your perspective in my personal opinion
you're reading into things that I don't
think kids will pick up at all awesome
and also to this is what I believe
because mind you too like I'm talking
about like we grew up in a generation
where Disney was huge you know and I've
never really seen that effect of like I
can understand the whole Prince Charming
effect do you understand what I'm saying
but for me right now
you're also trying to do this thing
where I see it as you're also trying to
shield your kid from stuff that they're
gonna see with or without you she
watches this he I take it or watch
Disney for sure but that's what I can't
stop no I'm not gonna stop her but I
will limit her you know I will limit the
amount of what she watches and what she
you know like there's no way she's gonna
grow up and not being able to watch it
she'll do it behind my back I get that
but what what I'm telling you is when
you have a child and you see what
they're you're listening to what they're
saying you start understanding what
these shows and these movies actually
[ __ ] what what is imbedded in their
brain my daughter only thinks princes
are blonde haired girls I'm being honest
and you know I don't you think she
thinks princes are blonde hair they're
only blonde dresses princesses are only
blonde haired girls no shade in that
there's no shade but the fact that you
know this is like I bought this I bought
this thing where it's a bunch of
stickers of just a bunch of girls and
you could trust them however you want
and this is where I really noticed it
where she picked all the blonde girls
and make them very pretty and put crowns
on them and she was and she was like
this is a princess she's so beautiful
and she'll pick out any other race and
I'm like is she a princess - she's like
no she's ugly hmm because even as a
nation you know like her as an agent
like she doesn't think she's a princess
she was I I'm not
princess and so I was like whoa [ __ ]
this is why I think it is deeper and
when you have a child you you will start
seeing oh I'm just talking about the
magic carpet and that and that thieving
scene oh no I agree that part yeah I
mean like I'm saying like those imagery
the the imagery of the whole princess
thing and the Prince Charming thing
because it's a theme that happens so
often in these older Disney films like I
completely get that I was just talking
about that I get it that could take it
to another level that's all about we're
talking about two separate days yeah
that was because I was on a roll with
all this like I was realize for sure I
mean yeah - you'll definitely see that -
cuz like you know in these toys that
kids see they they'll pick out the ones
that they'll see in these films a lot
because that's people that they'll want
to like emulate a lot right so that's
why in media now a lot of people are
fighting for these diverse characters to
have these type of roles because they're
want they want their kids to understand
that you know you could be a princess
you'll be a hero in your own story and
you could do it by looking the way that
you do now exactly and I think they you
know things are changing but I do have
to be honest with you that's what my
daughter that's what my daughter says so
you know I'm just trying to now you know
what if you asked cares like it's mommy
a pretty she goes no I'm not a princess
last year room mommy is a princess all
right you see that's no point no you
wait marry grow you a princess oh yeah
you're right I'm good with that charming
like saving me cuz I remember watching
Little Mermaid and I do it came to a
point in my life where I was like well
why do I think like this